hello and welcome to this video I have
not yet changed the number no half we
can't be a MIDI playing against me but
other comments exchanged I don't think
that's a good water
no black lost quite a bit of time there
and you don't have a clear plan now how
to develop your pieces you probably have
to push the upon he does not push the
upon how is he ever going to develop
don't quite know really happy to get
Bishop I mean not because of the bishop
pair so much but how is he going to play
e6 without a LightSquared bishop that's
that's the question that's a bit bit
mind-boggling how is he ever playing the
e pawn I mean if you play now I'll take
played Bishop d3 and black is busted
it's not a position you can stand it b7
is hanging on top of it but just simply
the position after a pawn takes F takes
Bishop d3 is a disaster yeah it's the
question Bishop d3 just playing a
position on Queen b7 grab stuff now this
is stronger also Queen h4 which is
irritating yeah I expected that but
after castling next night before is just
around the corner yeah the question is
take again no I'm not taking this
you know I'm ready for night for bishops
III
okay so the Queen might go to D for
[Music]
somewhat somewhat annoying their age
five
maybe nighty to was actually better than
94 covered g3 prepare bishop c3 yeah
yeah seems fine not sure it was best
something but black is definitely under
pressure
yeah I kind of hope you don't want to
play really you're black
yeah and so bishops III would be the
simplest way to play because device kind
of end really happy to see that and he's
going to play before there's no other
move simply okay
there is another move I don't
I did not really take that into account
okay if I take it porn Teague's hmm
okay 93 No
hmm Queen chef Sevan really did not have
this on the radar or the head I would
have played differently definitely would
have played differently yes okay i
blundered that I just blundered that
being so irritated really strange what I
want my thought process was there I have
no clue I mean really really weird why
did I not really think about Queen f7
all that much it's not exactly rocket
science or anything Nancy for Queenie
form so that's not a problem I think
probably I'm overlooking a one move
again but not sure what that might be
Queen g6
yeah Bishop c4 doesn't work and believe
really what I'm doing him okay I only
have seven seconds it's not going for a
draw no it is a drive wanted to deviate
now because it is such a such a meek way
of playing it's okay it's too late now
that's it's really a terrible result
I mean blacks opening is just simply
unplayable like here I expect like plus
two point something here for white one
point they are given enough time it will
go to plus two that's absolutely no
question this is atrociously bad for
black I mean your light squares are
toast and everything is just terrible d5
really that Q kind of what really that's
crazy
like this is a playable position you
have to be kidding me
it's amazing that's amazing
I didn't didn't take that into account
when you have to do something else then
Bishop d3 play Bishop b2 and Castle long
that's actually trickier we cancel own
not bad
so he could have played d5 that's very
crazy okay Bishop d2 which was
unnecessary I can Castle actually
because he three is protected yeah yeah
now okay was winning don't don't give me
that and now d5 is actually playable
from like what okay I mean okay it is
playable because Bishop c3 yes I
understand because Queen f7 is possible
I still find it hard to believe that
this is supposed to be good for black I
mean it's got no structure whatsoever
yeah okay I've got clumsy position
pieces clumsily position pieces this is
funny yeah you think like a minute or so
and then blunder 93 I didn't I didn't
even see that this was a threat I mean
not not in the slightest
that's really remarkable I mean the
opening play it's just black should just
not have a game it's just too bad and it
is actually it's so difficult it is
still difficult to do and here here the
engine gives some improvements
Bishop d3 I mean there should be like
almost a clean win here it's not a sorry
yeah B should be - we're getting 1 point
something or Bishop d3
you obviously have to be more precise I
mean the position must be terrible but
you have to you have to be more precise
we should be to etext e5 c5 it's a very
nice idea I had the idea to play c5 but
obviously I didn't see this kind of this
kind of news or in particular this is
the point like being very good with this
chick and something like that that looks
really bad so this is the way to punish
like remarkable so I mean I evaluation
was correct though you have to be far
more precise and yeah I'm actually
winning Queen e2 wins why exactly
I didn't see anything yet I mean isn't
the night hanging then here that is
winning yeah okay Kim yeah it's kind of
forgivable yeah that I didn't see that I
[Music]
wanted to continue somehow Oh
Queenie I would have played I think we
need to was my idea hmm it's really
amazing yeah yeah you have to be far
more precise here even though it looks
completely bad this should be two is a
lot better really even Bishop d3 is
special that they're being to take with
the line yeah that's much better
okay guys thanks for watching